In every low-income neighborhood in every city in the United States, there are people trying to make things better. Ministers, teachers, social workers. If you have one of those jobs, sometimes the best way to get through each day is to think small. Get this one parent off drugs. Get this one kid through the school year. Deal with stuff you can actually fix. But Geoffrey Canada grew up poor in the South Bronx raised by a single mom on welfare. Somehow he managed to make it out of the neighborhood to a good college in Maine, then off to Harvard.
在美国每一个城市的低收入社区里，都有人试图让一切变得更好。牧师、教师、社会工作者。如果你从事这些工作，有时度过每一天最好的方式就是想得小一点。帮这一个家长戒毒。帮这一个孩子完成学业。处理你能真正解决的事情。但杰弗里·卡纳达是在南布朗克斯贫困长大的，由靠救济金生活的单亲母亲抚养。他不知何故设法走出了那个社区，进入了缅因州的一所好大学，然后去了哈佛。
But he wanted to help kids like the ones he'd grown up with. So he came back to New York City, took over a community organization in Harlem. This group did a really good job. They helped a lot of kids stay in school, keep out of trouble. But after a decade in this job, Geoffrey Canada started to get frustrated. Things were getting worse in Harlem. Fewer kids were graduating high school. Incarceration rates were rising, poverty was on the rise. And that's when he decided to make a change and go big.
但他想帮助像他一起长大的那些孩子。于是他回到纽约市，接管了哈雷姆区的一个社区组织。这个团体做得非常好。他们帮助许多孩子坚持上学，远离麻烦。但在从事这份工作十年后，杰弗里·卡纳达开始感到沮丧。哈雷姆区的情况正在恶化。高中毕业的孩子越来越少。监禁率在上升，贫困在加剧。就在那时，他决定做出改变，干一场大的。
Today on our radio show, we have three stories of people deciding that they are going to pull out all the stops. They're going to go to extreme, audacious lengths. They're going to do things that not only have they never heard of, I think nobody's ever heard of, for their communities, for their families, for the people they care for. It is This American Life , by the way, from WBEZ Chicago, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. In Act two of today's show, we have somebody going to really absurd lengths-- I think I can say that-- to win over a woman. In Act three, we have a daughter reaching out to her mom using means I believe anyone would find extraordinary. And let's get right to it.
今天在我们的广播节目中，我们有三个关于人们决定孤注一掷的故事。他们打算采取极端、大胆的举措。他们将为他们的社区、他们的家庭、他们所关心的人做一些不仅是他们从未听说过，我想也没人听说过的事情。顺便说一句，这是来自芝加哥WBEZ的《美国生活》，由公共广播国际分发。我是艾拉·格拉斯。在今天节目的第二幕中，我们有一位采取了非常荒谬的手段——我想我可以这么说——来赢得一个女人的心。在第三幕中，我们有一位女儿通过我相信任何人都会认为非常规的方式联系她的母亲。让我们直接开始吧。
Act one, an act that we're calling Harlem Renaissance, we have the story of Geoffrey Canada and what happened when he decided to go big. Paul Tough tells that story.
第一幕，我们称之为“哈雷姆文艺复兴”，我们讲述杰弗里·卡纳达的故事，以及他决定干一场大的之后发生了什么。保罗·塔夫讲述了这个故事。
The thing that changed Geoffrey Canada's thinking about the best way to help poor children was having a child of his own. This was 10 years ago, when he was in his mid-40s. It wasn't his first time being a father. That was a whole generation earlier, when he was still in college, a poor kid from a rough neighborhood on scholarship. That first marriage didn't last long, but in his early 40s, he remarried. And a couple of years later, he and his new wife had a son they named Geoffrey Jr.
改变杰弗里·卡纳达关于帮助贫困儿童最佳方式想法的事情，是他有了自己的孩子。这是10年前，当时他四十多岁。这不是他第一次当父亲。那是在整整一代人之前，当时他还在上大学，是一个来自贫困社区的领奖学金学生。那次婚姻没持续多久，但在他四十出头时，他再婚了。几年后，他和新婚妻子生了一个儿子，取名小杰弗里。
Things were a lot different in his second go-around as a dad. He was no longer a struggling young father trying to make ends meet. He was now a well-educated, upper middle class guy living in a big home in the suburbs, surrounded by trees and lawns and golf courses. His life had changed in the 25 years since his first child was born. And he found out that parenting had changed too, for his neighbors at least. There was a ton of new research on the importance of stimulating your child's brain early on. And apparently every parent in the suburbs had heard about these studies because they were obsessed with preparing their infants. Baby Einstein tapes, flash cards, brain-building toys. Everyone was doing it.
在他第二次当爸爸时，情况大不相同了。他不再是一个努力维持生计的年轻父亲。他现在是一个受过良好教育、中上阶层的人，住郊区的大房子里，周围有树木、草坪和高尔夫球场。在他第一个孩子出生后的25年里，他的生活发生了变化。他发现育儿也变了，至少对他的邻居们来说是这样。有大量关于尽早刺激孩子大脑重要性的新研究。显然郊区的每个家长都听说过这些研究，因为他们痴迷于准备婴儿的教育。爱因斯坦宝宝录影带、闪卡、大脑开发玩具。每个人都在做。
I just found it fascinating that since I had raised my first children, the amount of information about what we should be doing in that period of time was really quite staggering. And I thought I was a pretty good parent in the early years. But now I'm looking and thinking I was not a great parent at all if you really looked at what they said is happening in a child's developmental process between zero and three. And I found that Yvonne, my wife, and I were spending all kinds of time thinking about how to get little Geoffrey prepared for the world he was going to inherit when he became a grown man.
我只是觉得很迷人，自从我抚养第一个孩子以来，关于我们在那段时间应该做什么的信息量确实相当惊人。我认为我在头几年是一个相当不错的父亲。但现在我回头看，如果真的看看他们所说的孩子从零岁到三岁的发展过程中发生了什么，我根本不是一个伟大的父亲。我发现我和妻子伊冯花了很多时间思考如何让小杰弗里为他成年后将要继承的世界做好准备。
And Geoff started to think, well, if he was overwhelmed by all this new information, what about the parents he was working with in Harlem? He turned to his staff at the organization he ran and asked them to canvas the neighborhood and find out what this new parenting revolution looked like from the streets of Harlem.
杰夫开始想，好吧，如果他都被所有这些新信息淹没了，那他在哈雷姆一起工作的那些家长呢？他转向他管理的组织的员工，要求他们去社区进行走访，看看这场新的育儿革命从哈雷姆的街道上看是什么样子。
There was nothing. We couldn't find one place that was teaching anything to children zero to three. And it suddenly struck me that places like Central Harlem are often left out of the science around youth development. All of us were just absorbing this. It was in magazines and on TV and on the radio. Everybody was saying, oh, yeah yeah yeah. I've got to be thinking about this child's brain. At the same time, it was skipping by Central Harlem.
什么都没有。我们找不到一个教授零到三岁儿童任何东西的地方。我突然想到，像哈雷姆中心区这样的地方往往被排除在青年发展的科学之外。我们所有人都只是在吸收这些。它在杂志、电视和广播里。每个人都在说，哦，是的是的是的。我必须考虑这个孩子的大脑。与此同时，它却跳过了哈雷姆中心区。
During this same period, Geoff's thinking was evolving in another way as well. After so many years of frustration, of saving one kid and watching 10 more slip through his fingers, he begin to wonder. What if instead of reaching 5% or 10% of the kids in Harlem, he could reach 40 or 50 or 60% of them? Maybe there was a tipping point where the whole culture of the neighborhood would start to change, where teenage pregnancy and going to prison and dropping out would be considered strange behaviors, instead of something you just expect, the normal course of events. So with all these ideas in his head, he went before his board of directors and said we have to rethink everything.
在同一时期，杰夫的想法也在以另一种方式演变。在经历了这么多年的挫折，拯救了一个孩子却看着另外10个从指缝中溜走后，他开始怀疑。如果他能接触到哈雷姆40%、50%或60%的孩子，而不是5%或10%，会怎样？也许存在一个临界点，整个社区的文化会开始改变，青少年怀孕、坐牢和辍学会被认为是奇怪的行为，而不是你所预期的那种正常事件。所以带着脑子里的这些想法，他来到董事会面前说，我们必须重新思考一切。
In order to truly make a difference, in order to change the outcome for this community, to end the generational poverty, saving 500 kids, 1,000 kids, 1,500 kids simply was not going to make a difference. We were going to have to operate in a really different way. We had to really think big. So we were going to have to work with children in the thousands and going to 10,000 children. But we also were going to have to work with children starting from birth right through until they graduated from college.
为了真正有所作为，为了改变这个社区的结果，结束代际贫困，仅仅拯救500个、1000个、1500个孩子根本无法带来改变。我们必须以一种真正不同的方式运作。我们必须真正想得大。所以我们必须与成千上万的孩子一起工作，达到一万个孩子。但我们也必须从孩子出生起就一直工作到他们大学毕业。
We're about to get started. You see staff around the  room with green shirts on. First, I'd like to introduce to you the Assistant Director of Baby College, Mr. Abasi Clark.
我们马上就要开始了。你看到房间周围穿着绿色衬衫的工作人员。首先，我想向你们介绍“宝宝学院”的助理院长，阿巴斯·克拉克先生。
I'm in a cafeteria in a Central Harlem elementary school, surveying what, 10 years later, Geoffrey Canada's vision has become-- an organization called the Harlem Children's Zone. A program unlike anything else in the country. It represents a complete rethinking of the way we've been dealing with urban poverty. The scope of Geoff's ambition is huge, to reach almost every child living in 97 inner-city blocks in Central Harlem, 10,000 kids in all, and make sure they all graduate from high school and get through college. To give you a sense of what that means, 10 years ago, only a little more than half the kids in Harlem even finished high school.
我身处哈雷姆中心区一所小学食堂，正在考察10年后杰弗里·卡纳达的愿景变成了什么样子——一个名为“哈雷姆儿童地带”的组织。这是一个全国独一无二的项目。它代表了我们处理城市贫困方式的彻底重构。杰夫的目标范围非常巨大，要覆盖哈雷姆中心区97个内城街区里几乎所有的孩子，总共1万名孩子，并确保他们都高中毕业并读完大学。为了让你了解这意味着什么，10年前，哈雷姆只有不到一半的孩子完成了高中学业。
To make this happen, he's grown his organization to 10 times its original size, built a comprehensive system of integrated services, going from cradle to college. There are two charter schools, a health clinic, a family counseling center, even a farmer's market and free tax preparation. But first, he's concluded, he needs to get Harlem's parents on board. He wants them to rethink how to raise their kids, to show them what middle class parents are doing. And that starts right here in Baby College.
为了实现这一目标，他将组织规模扩大了10倍，建立了一个从摇篮到大学的综合集成服务系统。那里有两所特许学校、一个诊所、一个家庭咨询中心，甚至还有一个农贸市场和免费税务准备。但首先，他断定，他需要让哈雷姆的家长们参与进来。他希望他们重新思考如何抚养孩子，向他们展示中产阶级父母在做什么。这一切都始于“宝宝学院”。
All right. One, two, three. If you're happy and you know it, clap your hands. If you're happy and you know it, clap your hands.
好的。一、二、三。如果你快乐你就拍拍手。如果你快乐你就拍拍手。
Scientists have concluded that the most effective time to intervene in the lives of poor kids is between the ages of zero and three, when the only people who can really give that help are the parents. And so for the last two months, a full-time team of 15 outreach workers has been roaming the streets of Harlem, going door to door in housing projects and stopping random pregnant women at the supermarket or on the subway, grabbing anyone pushing a stroller, trying to persuade them to give up nine Saturday mornings in a row to take classes on how to be a better parent.
科学家们得出结论，干预贫困儿童生活最有效的时期是零到三岁之间，当时唯一真正能提供这种帮助的人就是父母。因此，在过去的两个月里，一个由15名外联人员组成的全职团队一直在哈雷姆的街头游走，挨家挨户敲开住房项目的门，在超市或地铁站拦住随机的孕妇，抓住每一个推着婴儿车的人，试图说服她们放弃连续九个星期六的早晨，去上课学习如何成为更好的家长。
--know it, shout hooray. Hooray! If you're happy and you know it, shout hooray. Hooray!
……知道就大喊万岁。万岁！如果你快乐你就大喊万岁。万岁！
The idea of trying to mess around in the private life of a disadvantaged family is one that makes a lot of people uncomfortable. It's essentially telling poor parents that there's a better way to raise your kids, and we're going to tell you how. But somehow, that's not what it feels like at Baby College. It feels like a conversation, like we're on your side. Like it'll be fun.
试图干涉弱势家庭私生活的想法会让很多人感到不舒服。这本质上是在告诉贫困的家长，有更好的方法抚养你的孩子，我们要告诉你怎么做。但不知为何，在“宝宝学院”感觉并不像那样。它感觉像是一场对话，像是我们站在你这一边。像是这会很有趣。
Hooray!
万岁！
Hold on, hold on, hold on, hold on, hold on, hold on, hold on. Listen, listen. Usually I don't do this, but it's the first week, and I'm feeling good. I'm happy to see all you parents out today in this hot weather. So we're going to have some fun, just a little bit of fun, real quick.
等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等。听着，听着。通常我不这样做，但这是第一周，我感觉很好。我很高兴今天在这么热的天气里看到你们所有的家长来这里。所以我们要玩得开心点，就一点点，很快。
For the last five years, I've been writing a book about Geoffrey Canada's effort to go big. I spent this summer with the parents in Baby College. For most of these kids, if everything goes according to Geoffrey Canada's plan, this will be the beginning of a lifetime of involvement with the Harlem Children's Zone. And it's Baby College that sets the whole thing in motion, and in the process, challenges many assumptions about what is and isn't possible for a social program to tackle.
在过去的五年里，我一直在写一本关于杰弗里·卡纳达干大事业努力的书。今年夏天我和“宝宝学院”的家长们待在一起。对于这些孩子中的大多数来说，如果一切都按照杰弗里·卡纳达的计划进行，这将是他们与“哈雷姆儿童地带”终身接触的开始。而正是“宝宝学院”启动了这一切，在这个过程中，挑战了许多关于社会项目能或不能解决什么问题的假设。
[BEAT BOXING] Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
[口技] 等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等。
After five years of reporting, I've come to believe, as Geoffrey Canada does, that there is a solution to poverty in America. And on this morning anyway, that solution sounds something like this.
经过五年的报道，我开始相信，正如杰弗里·卡纳达所认为的那样，美国存在解决贫困的办法。至少在今天早上，那个办法听起来是这样的。
[BEAT BOXING]
[口技]
If you're happy and you know it, stomp your feet. If you're happy and you know it, stomp your feet. If you're happy and you know it, and you really want to show it, if you're happy and you know it, stomp your feet. If you're happy and you know it--
如果你快乐你就跺跺脚。如果你快乐你就跺跺脚。如果你快乐，你真的想表现出来，如果你快乐你就跺跺脚。如果你快乐你就……
Good morning. How are you all feeling today? Good? Does everyone have their binder with them today?
早安。你们今天感觉怎么样？好吗？今天每个人都带了活页夹吗？
In a classroom down the hall from the cafeteria, a dozen expecting parents are sitting in a half circle, perched on those hard little elementary school chairs. They're listening to their instructor, Hassan. Today's class is all about brain development. And Hassan is talking about all the ways that parents can help their children's brains to grow-- singing songs, playing games, talking, and most importantly, reading to them.
在离食堂走廊尽头的一间教室里，十几位准父母坐在半圆形的圈子里，栖身在那些硬邦邦的小学椅子上。他们正在听讲师哈桑讲课。今天的课是关于大脑发育的。哈桑正在谈论家长可以帮助孩子大脑发育的所有方式——唱歌、玩游戏、交谈，最重要的是，给他们读书。
The more you introduce language to them, the more they grab it. So at their earliest ages, your child has a brain capacity that's way past where we are.
你向他们引入的语言越多，他们吸收的就越多。所以在最早的年龄，你孩子的大脑容量远远超过我们。
A lot of what gets taught in Baby College-- that you should read to your kid every night, use timeouts instead of corporal punishment-- is the stuff that Geoffrey Canada discovered in the suburbs. Knowledge that over the last couple of decades has made its way into pretty much every middle and upper middle class home in America, but barely penetrated low-income neighborhoods like Harlem.
“宝宝学院”教授的大部分内容——你应该每晚给孩子读书、使用“暂停”时间代替体罚——都是杰弗里·卡纳达在郊区发现的东西。这些知识在过去几十年里已经渗透到美国几乎每一个中产阶级和中上阶级家庭，但却几乎没有进入像哈雷姆这样的低收入社区。
The only way that they can be acquainted with all of that is that you are doing that. And that starts now.
他们熟悉这一切的唯一方式就是你正在这样做。而且现在就开始。
There's lots of science to back up what Hassan is saying. One research project that underlies everything that happens in Baby College was done in the 1980s in Kansas City. A pair of psychologists did a closeup study of two sets of families. One group, in which the parents were on welfare, and another, in which the parents held professional jobs.
有很多科学证据支持哈桑所说的话。作为“宝宝学院”所发生一切基础的研究项目之一，是20世纪80年代在堪萨斯城完成的。一对心理学家对两组家庭进行了近距离研究。一组家长的福利救济，另一组家长从事专业工作。
It turned out that the biggest difference between the two sets of homes was language. The kids with the professional parents heard 20 million more words in the first three years of their lives than the kids on welfare, mostly just the regular jabber-jabber of parents talking to their children. And those extra words had a huge effect on their verbal ability. It was stunning news that the biggest factor in determining a child's later success in school wasn't any of the things we always assumed to be true. It wasn't money. It wasn't parental education. It wasn't race. It was the sheer number of words your parents spoke to you as a child. Among scholars who study inequality, there is more and more evidence out there that the divide between the kids who make it and the kids who don't starts in the very first years of life. The researcher who has done the best job of pulling all this together is a man named James Heckman.
结果发现，这两组家庭之间最大的区别是语言。专业人士家庭的孩子在生命的前三年里比福利救济家庭的孩子多听到了2000万个单词，大部分只是父母与孩子交谈时的日常碎碎念。而这些额外的单词对他们的语言能力产生了巨大的影响。这是一则令人震惊的新闻，决定孩子后来在学校成功与否的最大因素不是我们一直认为理所当然的任何事情。不是钱。不是家长的教育程度。不是种族。而是你作为孩子时父母对你说的单词总量。在研究不平等问题的学者中，越来越多的证据表明，成功与不成功的孩子之间的分歧始于生命的最初几年。最出色地将这一切整合在一起的研究人员是一位名叫詹姆斯·赫克曼的人。
Well, like many economists and students, really, of the American labor market, one is always interested in why some people earn more and do better in the labor market, do better in life than others.
嗯，就像许多经济学家和学生，真正地，对美国劳动力市场而言，人们总是对为什么有些人赚得更多，在劳动力市场上表现更好，在生活中表现得比别人更好感兴趣。
Heckman is an economist at the University of Chicago. In the early '90s, he was hired to study some government programs aimed at adolescents from poor neighborhoods-- all the traditional solutions to poverty we've been using for the last 40 years. Things like job training, GED programs, programs for dropouts. And much to his surprise, he found that none of these programs were actually working. Job training was supposed to be the solution to welfare. But Heckman found that for the young adults he was studying, it wasn't doing any good at all.
赫克曼是芝加哥大学的经济学家。在90年代初，他受雇研究一些针对贫困社区青少年的政府项目——即过去40年来我们一直使用的所有解决贫困的传统方案。比如职业培训、GED（同等学历）项目、辍学生项目。令他惊讶的是，他发现这些项目实际上都没有起作用。职业培训本应是解决福利问题的方案。但赫克曼发现，对于他所研究的年轻人来说，它根本没有任何好处。
The premise behind job training is that young people who can't find a good job are just missing one particular skill or body of knowledge. Teach them that and they'll be fine. What Heckman found is that the people in these programs had a much bigger problem. There were some very basic skills and abilities that they had never learned. And it was hard for them to absorb anything new without those skills. Things like--
职业培训背后的前提是，找不到好工作的年轻人只是缺少某项特定技能或知识。教给他们，他们就会好起来。赫克曼发现的是，这些项目中的人们有一个更大的问题。他们从未学过一些非常基本的技能和能力。而没有这些技能，他们很难吸收任何新东西。比如——
--the ability to communicate, to solve simple mathematical puzzles, and to understand how to even read the newspaper. As well as the non-cognitive-- self control, motivation, ability to get out of the bed, to show up at work on time, to engage and be open to ideas. These traits were in very serious short supply for individuals that I was looking at, the disadvantaged. And so I came to ask the question, how is it that these skills get formed?
——沟通能力、解决简单数学难题的能力，以及甚至如何读报纸。还有非认知能力——自我控制、动力、起床、准时上班、参与并开放接受思想的能力。这些特质在我所观察的弱势群体中严重短缺。所以我开始问这个问题，这些技能是如何形成的？
As Heckman continued his research, he discovered some good news and some bad news. The bad news was that if kids don't get these very basic skills pretty early in life, ideally before reaching kindergarten, then those skills become harder and harder to acquire. If you haven't achieved basic reading fluency by eight or nine or 10, it's very hard to learn after that.
随着赫克曼继续他的研究，他发现了一些好消息和一些坏消息。坏消息是，如果孩子在生命早期，理想情况下在幼儿园之前，没有获得这些非常基本的技能，那么这些技能就变得越来越难获得。如果你在八、九或十岁时还没有实现基本的阅读流利度，之后就很难再学了。
And if by adolescence you haven't learned those non-cognitive skills like patience and self control, the odds are stacked against you ever learning those. But the good news was that the reverse was also true. If you can get to a poor child early on, in the first few years of life, even small interventions can have huge effects.
而且如果到了青春期你还没有学会那些像耐心和自我控制这样的非认知技能，你很可能永远学不会了。但好消息是反过来也是如此。如果你能尽早接触到贫困儿童，在生命的最初几年，即使是很小的干预也能产生巨大的影响。
Discipline is always a big to-do.
纪律总是件大事。
In the course of writing my book, I went through Baby College a few times. And every time, the discipline classes were the most intense. And they were the hardest sell with the parents. That language study that discovered that well-off kids hear 20 million more words than poor kids before age three also found that the kind of language poor kids hear is different. The researchers counted the number of encouraging and discouraging remarks that children heard from their parents. And the difference between the two groups was staggering.
在写书的过程中，我去了几次“宝宝学院”。每一次，纪律课都是最强烈的。它们也是家长们最难接受的部分。那个发现富裕家庭的孩子在三岁前比贫困家庭的孩子多听到2000万个单词的语言研究，也发现贫困儿童听到的语言类型是不同的。研究人员统计了孩子们从父母那里听到的鼓励和挫败性言论的数量。两组之间的差异非常惊人。
By age three, a child of professionals hears about 500,000 encouragements and 80,000 discouragements. A child of parents on welfare hears almost the exact opposite, just 80,000 encouragements and 200,000 discouragements. According to the scientists who study this stuff, physical and verbal punishment has a huge effect on a child's emotional development, and on cognitive development too. For most parents in Baby College, though, these were pretty foreign ideas.
到三岁时，专业人士的孩子听到了约50万次鼓励和8万次打击。而福利救济家庭的孩子听到的几乎完全相反，只有8万次鼓励和20万次打击。据研究这些东西的科学家称，身体和语言惩罚对孩子的情绪发育有巨大的影响，对认知发育也是如此。然而对于“宝宝学院”的大多数家长来说，这些都是相当陌生的观念。
What other ways can you-- oh, now let me see. One, two, three, four. Give me another one for ways to handle discipline.
还有什么其他方法可以你……哦，让我看看。一、二、三、四。给我另一个处理纪律的方法。
Dominique's class is for parents of children under a year old. The kids are all sitting on the carpet in the middle of a circle of chairs, playing with blocks and rattles. And the kids don't know it, but Dominique is hard at work trying to keep them from getting hit, smacked, or popped by their parents, who are all sitting in a circle around the outside of the classroom. Dominique wants the parents to talk about alternatives to corporal punishment, like negotiating, timeouts, talking to a child. The parents don't seem all that convinced. One mother speaks up and says Dominique has forgotten to mention her favorite kind of discipline.
多米尼克的课是给一岁以下孩子的家长上的。孩子们都坐在教室中间圈椅子的地毯上，玩着积木和拨浪鼓。孩子们不知道，但多米尼克正在努力尝试不让他们被坐在教室周围圆圈里的父母打、拍或敲打。多米尼克希望家长们谈论体罚的替代方案，比如谈判、暂停时间、与孩子交谈。家长们似乎并不太信服。一位母亲发言说，多米尼克忘了提到她最喜欢的纪律方式。
Old-fashioned discipline. [SMACK]
老派纪律。[啪]
She pantomimes giving a child a smack. There's a feeling in the room that if the only tool you have to deal with your kid's acting up is to talk to them and just tell them to be good, they'll misbehave like crazy. As one mother puts it, for some children, sometimes you've just got to pop them.
她做出了打孩子一巴掌的动作。房间里有一种感觉，如果处理孩子胡闹的唯一工具就是和他们说话并告诉他们乖一点，他们会疯了一样胡作非为。正如一位母亲所说，对于某些孩子，有时你就是得打他们一下。
And popping them, you think, is going to stop that behavior for now. But what about later on? You're going to have to keep popping them?
而打他们，你认为，会暂时停止那种行为。但以后呢？你还得一直打他们？
No.
不。
Well, here is, what I think, is one of the things that frustrates a lot of us who live in and work in really poor communities.
嗯，我认为，这就是让我们许多在极贫困社区居住和工作的人感到沮丧的事情之一。
Again, Geoff Canada.
又是杰夫·卡纳达。
People telling kids sit down, shut up, get over here. Don't you make me come over there and get you. Do you hear me? And you just listen. That's a two-year-old you're talking to. Who talks to a two-year-old like that? Lots of people who really believe the parent's job is to make this child listen and become passive, so the child does whatever you want. A lot of our parents really believe that a child that looks like this is really a good child. And so you see all of this energy put into shutting a child down without the realization that that is how children's brains develop. A child's brain develops through exploring their world.
人们告诉孩子坐下、闭嘴、到这儿来。别让我过去抓你。你听见了吗？你在和一个两岁的孩子说话。谁会这样和两岁的孩子说话？很多人真的认为家长的职责是让孩子听话并变得被动，这样孩子就会做你想要的任何事。我们很多家长真的认为看起来这样的孩子才是好孩子。所以你看到所有的精力都投入到压制孩子身上，却没有意识到这就是儿童大脑发育的方式。孩子的大脑是通过探索他们的世界来发育的。
It's counterintuitive for many parents, this idea that a good kid isn't necessarily a quiet, well-behaved kid. So it isn't easy to convince them that this different style of parenting might actually work. But it's one of the amazing things about Baby College. You can actually see parents change their minds as the nine weeks go on. One young mother in the class speaks up and says that she's actually having second thoughts about popping her kids, the way she's done until now.
这种“好孩子不一定是一个安静、乖巧的孩子”的想法，对许多家长来说是违反直觉的。所以说服他们这种不同的育儿风格实际上可能有效并不容易。但这就是“宝宝学院”神奇的地方之一。你实际上可以在九周的过程中看着家长改变主意。班上一位年轻的母亲发言说，她实际上正在重新考虑打孩子的问题，即她到目前为止所做的方式。
Let me tell you something. Now he thinks he's grown. Now he thinks he can hit his brother when his brother behaves bad.
让我告诉你一件事。现在他认为他长大了。现在他认为当他哥哥表现不好时他可以打他。
And why do you think--
那你为什么认为……
He'll stand there and he'll go, come here, Chris. Come here. Let's go, let's go. I'm like, oh, wow.
他会站在那儿说，过来，克里斯。过来。我们走，我们走。我说，哦，哇。
So  wait a minute. Why do you think he's doing that?
等等，一会儿。那你为什么认为他在做那个？
Because I-- that doesn't work. He hits back now.
因为我……那不管用。他现在打回我了。
Unfortunately that's what you've taught him.
不幸的是，那就是你教他的。
Yeah.
是啊。
This idea that the habits of a parent are passed on to the child is not lost on anyone in the classroom. A lot of the parents are worried about imitating their own parents' behavior. Like this mother, Taisha, who said her mother's favorite form of communication is yelling.
这种父母的习惯传给孩子的想法对教室里的每个人来说并不陌生。很多家长担心模仿他们自己父母的行为。比如这位母亲泰莎，她说她母亲最喜欢的沟通方式就是大喊大叫。
And I'm like, talk to me. If you don't like something I did in the house as far as chores, tell me so I can correct it. But she doesn't talk. Like, when I was younger, she'd smoke cigarettes. I used to wish she would just smoke a cigarette after she starts yelling because that's when she'd calm down. So I'm like six years old, like, I hope she picks up that cigarette because I'm tired of hearing her mouth. Thinking about it now, that is crazy. I would not want my son to be thinking, oh ma, pick up that cigarette or that bottle of liquor because I'm tired of hearing your mouth. I have to do it a different way. I have--
我就想，和我谈谈。如果你对我家里的家务有意见，告诉我，我可以纠正。但她不谈。就像我小的时候，她会抽烟。我以前希望她在开始大吼大叫后能抽根烟，因为那时候她才会平静下来。所以六岁的我，就想，希望她拿起那根烟，因为我听够了她的唠叨。现在想想，那真是疯了。我不想让我的儿子在想，哦妈妈，拿起那根烟或那瓶酒，因为我听够了你的唠叨。我必须用不同的方式。我有——
So what other ways are some of the ways you do it now, as a parent?
那么作为家长，你现在还有什么其他做法？
As a parent, I haven't hit my son. Me and his father joke around, like, oh, we're going to have to hit this little boy. But I was like, let's try it the Baby College way. Let's see how this goes for a day. If their motives may not work, maybe I'll put a little of my stuff in it. But it has been working. It's tiring to keep doing the same thing over and over and over.
作为家长，我还没打过我儿子。我和他爸爸开玩笑说，哦，我们得打这个小男孩。但我说，我们试着按“宝宝学院”的方式来。看看一天效果如何。如果他们的方法不管用，也许我会加一点我自己的东西。但它一直有效。一直重复做同样的事情很累。
Academics and scholars who study poor communities often talk about the cycle of poverty. And when I sat down outside of class with Taisha, I realized that she saw herself the way the academics did, as a statistic.
研究贫困社区的学者和专家经常谈论贫困的恶性循环。当我课后和泰莎坐在一起时，我意识到她把自己视为学者眼中的统计数据。
I feel like I'm a statistic because I had a son, I was pregnant at 19. My mother was a young mother, was pregnant at 15. And I feel like every time I hold back another semester of college, it's like I'm never going to make it there. I was supposed to be the one to break that cycle. I was supposed to be the one doing right.
我觉得自己是个统计数据，因为我生了一个儿子，19岁时怀孕。我母亲是一位年轻的母亲，15岁时怀孕。我觉得每当我推迟一个学期的大学课程，我就好像永远无法达成目标。我本应是打破那个循环的人。我本应是那个做正确事情的人。
Taisha is 20. And she and her boyfriend [? Rossi ?] have a 10-month-old son named [? Rahsaan ?]. After class I talked with them for a while to try to get a sense of how much of a difference Baby College might make in their lives. They met in high school, it turned out. Taisha was one of the best students in her class. [? Rossi ?] was mostly interested in playing basketball. But when he started falling for Taisha, he knew he needed to pull up his grades to win her heart, so he hit the books. And when he graduated, he had a B average and a steady girlfriend. Taisha started college that fall. And then in December, she found out she was pregnant.
泰莎20岁。她和男友罗西有一个10个月大的儿子叫拉桑。课后我跟他们聊了一会儿，试图了解“宝宝学院”可能会给他们的生活带来多大改变。原来他们是在高中认识的。泰莎是班上最好的学生之一。罗西主要对打篮球感兴趣。但当他开始爱上泰莎时，他知道他需要提高成绩来赢得她的心，所以他努力学习。毕业时，他平均成绩为B，还有一个稳定的女朋友。泰莎在那年秋天开始上大学。然后12月，她发现自己怀孕了。
We initially planned to have an abortion. Well, I planned to have the abortion.
我们最初计划堕胎。嗯，我计划去堕胎。
I actually started crying when we were in the hospital, when she was about to get the abortion. So it was a hard decision.
在医院里，当她准备去堕胎时，我实际上开始哭了。所以这是一个艰难的决定。
Wow, so you were that close? You were in the--
哇，所以你们那么接近？你们在……
Yeah. I already convinced myself, like, this is what I'm going to do. Just go away for college and leave this in the past, leave [? Rossi ?] is the past, forget about it. But when I saw him crying, that broke me down. So I was like like, oh my God. I'm just going to do this.
是啊。我已经说服自己，这就是我要做的。去读大学，把这件事留在过去，让罗西成为过去，忘记它。但当我看到他哭的时候，那击垮了我。所以我当时想，天哪。我就要把它生下来。
But the decision didn't make her feel any better. She stayed depressed, didn't know what to do, fought with [? Rossi. ?] And then last spring, Taisha read about Baby College on a poster that an outreach worker had taped up in the lobby of the housing project where she was staying with her aunt. [? Rossi ?] agreed to come with her that first day, but he figured he'd just sit in the back and be a spectator. To his surprise, though, he ended up finding a lot of the information that first day really helpful. And he hasn't missed a class since.
但这个决定并没有让她感觉好受些。她一直很抑郁，不知道该怎么办，和罗西吵架。然后去年春天，泰莎在一张外联人员贴在她和姑妈住的住房项目大厅的海报上读到了“宝宝学院”。罗西同意第一天和她一起来，但他以为他只是会坐在后面当个观众。但令他惊讶的是，第一天他发现很多信息确实非常有帮助。从那以后他一节课都没落下。
It actually made our bond stronger with us. But it also gave us a greater bond with [? Rahsaan. ?] Just go back and tell him that, oh, you were in the Baby College when you were 10 months, seven months old. And we did that together as a family. I feel good about going there. I feel proud, actually, just doing this.
它实际上加强了我们的羁绊。但也让我们与拉桑有了更大的联系。回去告诉他，哦，你在7个月、10个月大时就在“宝宝学院”了。我们作为一家人一起做了那件事。我觉得去那里感觉很好。实际上，我为自己能做这件事感到自豪。
Yeah, I'm proud. When I go to work, I say I just came from Baby College. I am better as a parent, if I wasn't already. It just added on to it. I read to him every single night. Every night he gets a bath since he was born. But now, I read to him every night, about two to three books a night. Two to three books a night, even when I'm tired. They obviously convinced me that it works. And I see that he's able to sit there and actually just listen to me reading a story and get amazed at the pictures and the faces. And even if it's the same book being read to him over and over, he still has this excitement because it seems like it's something new every night, even if it's the same book. It's like, oh my God, is she reading a book again? Yes. You know?
是啊，我很自豪。当我去上班时，我说我刚从“宝宝学院”回来。我作为一名家长变得更好了，如果我本来就不错的话。它只是增添了它。我每天晚上都给他读书。自从他出生以来，他每天晚上都要洗澡。但现在，我每晚都给他读书，每晚两到三本书。每晚两到三本，即使我很累。他们显然说服了我，它有效。我看到他能够坐在那里，实际上只是听我读书，对画片和人脸感到惊奇。即使是同一本书反复读给他听，他仍然感到兴奋，因为看起来每晚都像是新的东西，即使是同一本书。就像，天哪，她在读书吗？是的。你知道吗？
When Taisha was growing up, she knew she wanted to have a different kind of life. But she didn't have anyone around her to show her what that looked like. Well, there was one family.
当泰莎成长时，她知道她想过一种不同的生活。但她周围没有人向她展示那是什么样子的。嗯，有一个家庭。
The Huxtables.
胡克丝一家。
It was watching The Cosby Show when she was a kid that gave Taisha an alternate vision for what her life might be like.
是小时候看《考斯比一家》给了泰莎对她未来生活可能的替代愿景。
This family, they had a family in a brownstone, a townhouse. And the kids went to college and they had other kids. And I want that. And being that I didn't see that around too much, I'm like, everybody's doing this. And it's not helping them. So let me try another path and see where can that take me? And if I can achieve what I'm seeing on TV, if it is achievable.
这个家庭，他们在一个棕色砂岩联排别墅里。孩子们上大学，还有其他孩子。我想要那个。考虑到我在周围没怎么见过，我就想，每个人都在做这个。但这并不能帮助他们。所以让我尝试另一条路，看看它能带我去哪里？如果我能实现我在电视上看到的东西，如果它是可实现的话。
For most middle class kids, the path that Taisha struggled to find is so straight and well-paved that they barely even notice it's there. Geoffrey Canada knows that he probably won't be able to create a Cosby Show environment for Taisha's son [? Rahsaan ?] or for any of the thousands of other kids in his programs. But he thinks that with the help of Taisha and [? Rossi ?], he can create a pretty good substitute. It's kind of a revolutionary idea. For years, we've been trying to improve the lives of poor children by improving the lives of their parents. Getting the parents better jobs or more money or better housing.
对于大多数中产阶级的孩子来说，泰莎努力寻找的那条路是如此笔直且平坦，他们几乎都没注意到它的存在。杰弗里·卡纳达知道他可能无法为泰莎的儿子拉桑或他项目中的成千上万其他孩子创造一个《考斯比一家》的环境。但他认为，在泰莎和罗西的帮助下，他可以创造一个相当不错的替代品。这是一个相当革命性的想法。多年来，我们一直试图通过改善贫困儿童父母的生活来改善儿童的生活。给家长更好的工作、更多的钱或更好的住房。
But Geoff is saying that we may be able to counter many of the effects of poverty on children without actually lifting their parents out of poverty. Just focus on the kids, get them through college, and then they can lift themselves out of poverty. The thing he invented to do this he calls the conveyor belt. In a couple of years, [? Rahsaan ?] will be eligible for the early lottery to get into one of the charter schools that the Harlem Children's Zone runs. If he gets in, his parents will have an opportunity to go through a more advanced parenting program called The Three-Year-Old Journey. The following year, [? Rahsaan ?] will have a guaranteed spot in Harlem Gems, the all-day prekindergarten.
但杰夫说，我们或许能够在不真正使他们的父母摆脱贫困的情况下，抵消贫困对儿童的许多影响。只需专注于孩子，让他们读完大学，然后他们就能自己摆脱贫困。他发明的东西他称之为传送带。几年后，拉桑将有资格参加提前抽签，进入“哈雷姆儿童地带”运营的特许学校之一。如果他进去了，他的父母将有机会通过一个更高级的名为“三岁之旅”的育儿项目。次年，拉桑将保证在“哈雷姆宝石”获得一个全天预科班名额。
Then he'll start school. And he can stay in the same school all the way to college, with plenty of after-school programs and social supports along the way. When he graduates from high school, [? Rahsaan ?] should have in front of him the kind of opportunities that very few kids used to have in Harlem, even if his parents never managed to turn into the Huxtables. But when I sat down with Geoff to discuss [? Rossi ?] and Taisha and their young son [? Rahsaan, ?] I realized that although Geoff is committed to his choice, save the kids rather than the parents, it still involves some painful trade-offs for him.
然后他将开始上学。他可以一直留在同一所学校直到读大学，一路拥有充足的课后项目和社会支持。当他从高中毕业时，拉桑面前应该拥有哈雷姆很少有孩子拥有的那种机会，即使他的父母从来没能变成“胡克丝一家”。但当我和杰夫坐下来讨论罗西和泰莎以及他们的小儿子拉桑时，我意识到，虽然杰夫致力于他的选择，拯救孩子而不是父母，但这对他来说仍然涉及一些痛苦的权衡。
It is probably one of the tougher decisions that I have made. But our choice is to focus on [? Rahsaan. ?] What we want to do is allow, I think, this child to have an opportunity not to repeat this same set of behaviors, meaning that he ends up getting someone pregnant and having to drop out of college to take care of them. And then you end up with the same cycle going over and over and over again.
这可能是我做出的最艰难的决定之一。但我们的选择是专注于拉桑。我们想做的是让这个孩子有机会不重复同样的行为模式，意思是最终他让某人怀孕，不得不辍学来照顾他们。然后你最终又陷入了同样的恶性循环，一次又一次。
It's hard, when you're just 19 or 20, to accept the idea that you're not the one who's going to make it out of poverty, that instead, your job is to make sure your kid makes it out. Taisha, especially, really struggles with that idea. Her Cosby Show dream seemed so close just a couple of years ago. But [? Rossi ?] and Taisha both say that the most important thing is to make sure the cycle that they're caught in doesn't claim [? Rahsaan ?] too.
当你只有19或20岁时，接受你不是那个能走出贫困的人，你的工作是确保你的孩子走出来，这很难。泰莎尤其对此感到挣扎。她的《考斯比一家》梦想就在几年前似乎还触手可及。但罗西和泰莎都说，最重要的是确保他们陷入的循环不会也索要了拉桑。
I want to break the cycle. And I want to start our own. And so he'll know that when he has his own kids that, oh, my parents were there for me. So I'm going to be there for my kids, and so forth and so forth. So it's basically starting our own generation.
我想打破循环。我想开始我们自己的。所以他会知道，当他有自己的孩子时，哦，我的父母在那里支持我。所以我也会在那里支持我的孩子，等等等等。所以这基本上是在开始我们自己的世代。
Well, if you can tell a parent, no no, you are getting that child ready right now. And this kid is actually going to have-- I know you don't have anything. And you don't have any money. I know you're worried about where the rent's going to come from. I know you're worried about, are you going to be able to provide for your child? Can you keep a roof over their head? But read to that child tonight. Just read to this child today. Just allow them an opportunity. You're doing as much for your child as that person in that nice, big house that you envy is doing for their child. As parents, you're exactly the same.
好吧，如果你能告诉一位家长，不不，你现在正让那个孩子做好准备。这个孩子实际上会拥有——我知道你什么都没有。你也没有钱。我知道你担心房租从哪里来。我知道你担心，你能不能负担得起你的孩子？能不能让他们有瓦遮头？但今晚给那个孩子读书。就今天给这个孩子读书。只需给他们一个机会。你为你孩子所做的事情，就像你羡慕的那个住在宽敞漂亮房子里的人为他们的孩子所做的一样。作为家长，你们完全一样。
I didn't read that much when I was younger. I watched a lot of TV. And we don't really let him watch TV like that. Maybe he watches Noggin when he gets home until it's time for him to go to bed. But if we read to him, he's going to start reading by himself. Just some little things like that, that just gets him adjusted so he could be better off.
我小的时候没读那么多书。我看了很多电视。我们真的不让他那样看电视。也许他回家后会看Noggin直到上床睡觉。但如果我们给他读书，他就会开始自己阅读。就像那些小事情，这让他适应，这样他就能过得更好。
If we can get this right for him, [? Rahsaan ?], and his generations that come from this point on, will have a totally different life. And he'll be going to that family reunion as a 28-year-old thinking, there's my mom and dad. And they really struggled. And they had it rough. But look how my life has been, and the life of my own children, which is what I think we're trying to do.
如果我们能为他做好这件事，拉桑，以及从这一点开始的世代，将拥有完全不同的生活。他将在28岁时以那个身份参加家庭聚会，心想，那是我的爸爸妈妈。他们确实挣扎过。他们确实过得很艰难。但看看我的生活，还有我孩子们的生活，这我想就是我们正在尝试做的事情。
I feel like there are some times you can look at everything that has to happen in a poor child's life to get them to successful outcomes. And you can just say, it's just enormous. There's just a ton of work that has to be done. But then there's other days where I feel I can look at it and feel the opposite. And feel like if you just read to your kid, just a couple little things are going to make a difference. And I'm wondering which way do you tend to look at it? Do you tend to be surprised at how easy it is, or tend to be surprised by how hard it is?
我觉得有时候你可以看看一个贫困孩子的生活中必须发生的一切才能让他们取得成功的结果。你可以说，这太巨大了。有大量的工作必须做。但也有其他日子我觉得我能看着它并感到相反。并觉得如果你只是给你的孩子读书，仅仅几个小东西就会带来改变。我很好奇你倾向于怎么看它？你倾向于对它如此简单感到惊讶，还是倾向于对它如此困难感到惊讶？
I am always surprised by how easy it is. It is not like decoding the human genome. You actually don't need eight supercomputers to do this. It takes people to really focus and concentrate. And I am always stunned-- well, how is it no one knows this? The reason it seems so incredibly difficult is that so few people have actually learned how to do it.
我总是对它如此简单感到惊讶。它不像破译人类基因组。你实际上并不需要八台超级计算机来做这件事。它需要人们真正专注。我总是感到震惊——嗯，为什么没人知道这个？它看起来如此难以置信的困难的原因是，很少有人真正学会了怎么做。
All the experts I interviewed for this story, and for my book, told me the same thing. It's much easier than people think. And so far, Geoff's efforts bear that out. The experiment is working. Think of what that means. For decades, we've thought that raising large numbers of kids out of poverty was basically impossible, that the best we could possibly hope to do was to pluck a few over-achievers out of the ghetto and airlift them into the middle class. But it turns out the only reason we thought it was so impossible to pull off was because we were doing it wrong.
我为这个故事以及我的书采访的所有专家都告诉了我同样的事情。它比人们想象的要容易得多。到目前为止，杰夫的努力证实了这一点。这个实验正在奏效。想想这意味着什么。几十年来，我们一直认为让大量贫困儿童摆脱贫困基本上是不可能的，我们能希望做的最好的事情就是从贫民窟里挑选几个拔尖人才，把他们空运进中产阶级。但事实证明，我们认为它无法实现的原因只是因为我们做错了。
Here's the data. Last year, the first group of kids in Geoff Canada's charter school made it to third grade, where they took their first New York state achievement tests. The results were astonishing. The class was all poor and African American, most in single-parent homes, some with parents who had been teenage mothers or high school dropouts or had trouble with the law. And they had reading scores above the New York City average. Their math scores were phenomenal, more than 95% of them on grade level. And these are kids who got to kindergarten before the conveyor belt was fully constructed. Most of them didn't attend the pre-kindergarten and their parents didn't go to Baby College.
这是数据。去年，杰夫·卡纳达特许学校的第一批孩子升入了三年级，在那里他们参加了第一次纽约州成绩测试。结果令人震惊。这个班级全是贫困的非裔美国人，大多数来自单亲家庭，有些父母曾是十几岁的母亲、高中辍学生或有法律纠纷。他们的阅读成绩高于纽约市平均水平。他们的数学成绩非常惊人，超过95%的孩子达到了年级水平。这些孩子在传送带完全建成之前就进入了幼儿园。他们中的大多数没有上过预科班，他们的父母也没有去过“宝宝学院”。
But the kids entering kindergarten now have been with the program since birth. They've been on the conveyor belt their whole lives. Which is why Geoff says that his best work is still to come. When these kids get to third grade, he says, look out. It's one of those things where it seems impossible until you see it done. It's not like we don't know how to raise a kid to succeed. We do it all the time in middle class neighborhoods. All it would take for things to change in Harlem is for us to decide that we want to do for kids there what we do for kids everywhere else.
但现在进入幼儿园的孩子从出生起就一直在这个项目中。他们一生都在传送带上。这就是为什么杰夫说他最好的工作还在后头。他说，当这些孩子升到三年级时，等着瞧。这就像那种看起来不可能直到你看到它完成的事情。并不是我们不知道如何抚养一个孩子去成功。我们在中产阶级社区里一直在做这件事。哈雷姆发生改变所需要的一切，就是我们要决定我们想为那里的孩子做我们在其他地方为孩子们所做的事情。
Paul Tough. He's one of the original editors of our radio show. His book about Geoffrey Canada and the Harlem Children's Zone is called Whatever It Takes. It just came out in paperback with a new afterword updating the story. And a lot has happened in that update. For starters, back when Barack Obama was running for president, he praised the Harlem Children's Zone for saving a generation of children up in Harlem.
保罗·塔夫。他是我们广播节目最初的编辑之一。他关于杰弗里·卡纳达和“哈雷姆儿童地带”的书叫《不惜一切代价》。它刚刚出了平装版，并附有一篇更新故事的新后记。在那个更新中发生了很多事情。首先，回到巴拉克·奥巴马竞选总统时，他称赞“哈雷姆儿童地带”拯救了哈雷姆的一代孩子。
There's no reason this program should stop at the end of those blocks in Harlem. And that's why when I'm President of the United States of America, the first part of my plan to combat urban poverty will be to replicate the Harlem Children's Zone in 20 cities across the country.
没有理由这个项目应该停留在哈雷姆的那些街区尽头。这就是为什么当我担任美利坚合众国总统时，我打击城市贫困计划的第一部分将是在全国20个城市复制“哈雷姆儿童地带”。
As president, he's trying to follow through, calling his program Promise Neighborhoods, and he is is targeting 20 cities with an initial investment of $10 million for planning grants and feasibility studies. If Congress approves his 2010 budget, the first planning grants could go out as early as this fall.
作为总统，他正试图贯彻到底，将他的项目称为“承诺社区”，他正瞄准20个城市，初步投入1000万美元用于规划赠款和可行性研究。如果国会批准他的2010年预算，第一批规划赠款最早可能在今年秋天发出。
Coming up, when the most romantic possible thing you can do is also the least romantic possible thing you can do. That's from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，当你能做的最浪漫的事情同时也是最不浪漫的事情时。来自芝加哥公共广播电台和公共广播国际，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life, I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our show, of course, we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, Going Big. Stories of people going full out, pulling out all the stops for those they care for. We have arrived at Act Two, Lonely Hearts Club Band... of One.
这里是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们选择一个主题，带给你关于这个主题的不同种类的故事。今天的节目，“干大的”。那些全力以赴，为他们关心的人孤注一掷的人们的故事。我们已经来到了第二幕，“孤独之心俱乐部乐队……独奏版”。
Not long ago, a musician named David Berkeley got a call from his booking agent, asking if he wanted to take a job that would be unlike any concert he had ever played. Berkeley is a singer-songwriter on the indie music circuit. He gets showcased at South by Southwest. He's toured with Rufus Wainwright and Billy Bragg and Ben Folds, people like that. And though he has played tons of shows all over the country, this one was different. He would fly to San Diego and play inside an apartment for just two people. And his goal would be to reunite the two as a couple.
不久前，一位名叫大卫·伯克利的音乐家接到了他的预订代理人的电话，询问他是否想接一份不同于他以往演奏过的任何音乐会的工作。伯克利是独立音乐圈的歌手兼词曲作者。他在“西南偏南”受到追捧。他曾与鲁弗斯·温莱特、比利·布拉格和本·福尔兹等人巡演。虽然他在全国各地举办过无数场演出，但这一场与众不同。他将飞往圣地亚哥，在一间公寓里只为两个人表演。他的目标将是让这两人重新成为一对情侣。
Now of course, most songwriters want to believe their music has the power to move people's hearts. But rarely does anybody test just how far that goes in such a clear-cut goal-oriented way. The guy in this couple wanted to be together. The woman, apparently, did not. Could David Berkeley sing them back together? Could this work? He wanted to believe it could.
现在当然，大多数词曲作者都希望相信他们的音乐有打动人心的力量。但很少有人以这样清晰、以目标为导向的方式测试它到底有多大作用。这对情侣中的那个人想在一起。那个女人，显然不想。大卫·伯克利能把他们唱回一起吗？这能行吗？他想相信可以。
He had sent me a long email with the battle plan, which the more I read, the more absurd it seemed. The couple had either met at one of my concerts in California, or their first date. I think their first date was at one of my concerts. And he was going to do everything he could to get her back. And I think that he decided that one huge gesture was probably what it would take. And so he planned this night from start to finish, which included going to their favorite restaurant and the wine that they were going to order. And then the culmination was going to be the nightcap in their apartment, where I was going to pop through the door and sing them their concert.
他给我发了一封带有战斗计划的长邮件，读得越多，它就显得越荒谬。这对情侣要么是在我在加州的一场音乐会上认识的，要么是他们的第一次约会。我想他们的第一次约会是在我的一场音乐会上。他准备竭尽全力把她追回来。我想他决定一个巨大的姿态可能就是所需要的。所以他从头到尾计划了这个夜晚，包括去他们最喜欢的餐厅和他们要点的酒。最后的高潮是他们在公寓里的睡前酒，我会从门外冒出来，给他们唱他们的音乐会。
And then he just gave me the plan for how I was going to sneak into the apartment without them knowing, and how I was going to have to actually sneak into the garage. Which literally involved me following a car in. And trying to get through the gate before the gate closed, and then up a back elevator onto the eighth floor, where I would then knock on his apartment door.
然后他就给了我计划，关于我如何偷偷进入公寓而不被他们发现，以及我如何实际上不得不偷偷溜进车库。这字面上涉及我跟着一辆车进去。在门关上之前设法通过大门，然后乘后部电梯到八楼，然后我会在那里敲他的公寓门。
Not to ask a dumb question, but couldn't he just send you a key?
不是问一个愚蠢的问题，难道他不能直接给你一把钥匙吗？
Yeah, I guess that didn't cross his or my mind. But yeah, he should have. And I was actually nervous. I play a lot of concerts, and rarely have I been nervous like this. And I guess it was because I had no idea what I was walking into. And I was about to knock on the door. And I started to think about, what is she going to do when I walk in? And I guess I expected that she was, despite feeling like things weren't going well, I thought she was going to be really excited to see me. And she would, I don't know what. She would give me a hug, or she would laugh, or something like that.
是啊，我想那没闪过他的或我的脑子。但是的，他本应该那样做。而且我实际上很紧张。我演奏过很多音乐会，很少像这样紧张。我想这是因为我不知道我将走进什么。而且我正要敲门。我开始想，当我走进去时她会怎么做？我想我预料到她会，尽管感觉事情进展不顺利，我想她会非常兴奋看到我。她会，我不知道怎么做。她会给我一个拥抱，或者她会笑，或者类似的事情。
And in fact, I opened the door and she just sort of crumpled. She sort of collapsed. Her head fell into her hands. And I think she might have said, I can't believe you did this. He shouldn't have done this. And it was hard for me, at this point, not to take that a little personally. Because without knowing it, I had kind of joined sides with this guy. I was on his team. We were coming in to do a job.
事实上，我打开门，她只是有点崩溃。她有点瘫倒了。她的头埋进了双手。我想她可能说了，我真不敢相信你这么做了。他不应该这么做的。这时，我不把这事往心里去有点难。因为不知不觉中，我有点站在了那个家伙那边。我是在他的团队里。我们是来做这项工作的。
OK, so what do you do?
好的，那么你该怎么做？
I think I said something like, hi. I thought I might play you a few songs. And it just felt gross. Why was I even here? And the guy asked me if I wanted to sit or stand. Which I normally stand when I perform, but that seemed completely absurd to me, that I was going to stand and perform to these two people in their living room. So I said I would sit. And he pulled a chair up for me. And I was across a small coffee table from them. And they sat down on the couch. And I sat down on my chair. And I started to play.
我想我说类似，嗨。我想我可能会给你们演奏几首歌。这感觉很糟糕。我为什么要在这儿？那个家伙问我是否想坐着还是站着。我通常表演时是站着的，但这对我来说显得完全荒谬，我将站着在这两个人的客厅里表演。所以我说我会坐下。他为我拉了一把椅子。我隔着一张小咖啡桌坐在他们对面。他们坐在沙发上。我坐在椅子上。我开始弹奏。
And so they're on the couch. And are they sitting close together?
所以他们坐在沙发上。他们坐得很近吗？
God, no. I think it was just a three-cushion couch and they were on the left and the right cushions. And there was a big cushion in between.
天哪，不。我想那只是个三座沙发，他们坐在左边和右边的垫子上。中间有一个大垫子。
Now, you have your guitar there. You and I are speaking to each other from different locations. Do you want to just play a couple lines of the song so we have a sense of what this was?
现在，你有你的吉他在那儿。你和我是在不同的地方交谈。你想演奏几句歌词，让我们对它有个概念吗？
Let me just tune real quick. OK.
让我快点调音。好的。
[PLAYING GUITAR]
[吉他演奏]
And I should stop right there. Because I got about that far in the song and glanced up. And that was enough for her to recognize the song and she started to cry, which wasn't what I had hoped would happen.
我就在那儿停下吧。因为我歌唱到那儿，抬头看了一眼。这足以让她认出这首歌，她开始哭了，这不是我希望发生的事情。
[PLAYING GUITAR AND SINGING] A couple on a bridge, a stone bridge in some European town. And after all the years, I see we all fall down. The knock at the front door, the crack in the wall. [END SINGING]
[吉他演奏和演唱] 一对情侣在桥上，某欧洲城镇的一座石桥上。多年以后，我看到我们都倒下了。敲前门的声音，墙上的裂缝。[演唱结束]
And right when I sang that part of the chorus-- the knock on the front door-- it seemed like suddenly I was actually singing a song that was the story of this night.
就在我唱到副歌的那部分时——敲前门的声音——似乎突然间我实际上唱了一首正是这个夜晚故事的歌。
Yeah, yeah. This is a song about a couple for whom things are not going very well.
是啊，是啊。这是一首关于一对情侣的歌，对他们来说事情进展得不太顺利。
Yeah. And why I didn't know that and think about that before I started to play it, I don't know. But it was too late. And this happens, at times, in a performance where you recognize you've made the wrong choice of a song. And you can never really go back. I had to just barrel through.
是啊。为什么我开始演奏前没意识到这一点并想到它，我不知道。但太晚了。在表演中有时会发生这种情况，你意识到你选错了歌。你永远无法真正回头。我不得不硬着头皮唱下去。
And so where do you go? What do you play next? What do you do?
那么你接下来去哪儿？你接下来弹什么？你做什么？
Well, I think I played a song that was a story song that was more lighthearted. And I got through that. But the night wasn't getting any easier. And also you have to understand that after a song finishes, two people clapping a couple of times after you finish a song sounds really, really depressing.
嗯，我想我弹了一首叙事歌曲，更轻松一点。我弹完了。但这个夜晚并没有变得更容易。而且你必须明白，当一首歌结束后，两个人在你演奏完后拍几下巴掌，听起来非常、非常令人沮丧。
I guess I didn't really stop to think about the fact that the song would end and they would either have to clap or not.
我想我没有真正停下来思考这样一个事实：歌会结束，他们要么必须鼓掌要么不鼓掌。
Well, that's why this was so weird. The time in between the songs became as painful as the songs themselves.
嗯，这就是为什么这很奇怪。歌曲之间的间歇变得和歌曲本身一样痛苦。
And so what do you do to try to turn the situation around?
那么你为了试图扭转局面做了什么？
Well, let me first say that as I'm singing that song, right after I sang the first lyric, I regretted the choice. And I started thinking ahead. And when I started racing through, in my mind, the other songs that I was going to be able to play this night, I started to get really scared. Because I realized that not only might it not have been a good idea to hire a musician to come across the country and sing to get back your girl, but I was probably the wrong musician to have hired.
嗯，让我首先说，当我在唱那首歌时，就在我唱第一句歌词之后，我后悔了我的选择。我开始预想。当我开始在脑海里飞速掠过我今晚能演奏的其他歌曲时，我开始感到非常害怕。因为我意识到，雇一个音乐家跨越全国去唱歌来追回你的女孩可能不仅不是一个好主意，而且我可能还是被雇错的音乐家。
Because of your melancholic--
因为你的忧郁……
Exactly.
没错。
--repertoire.
——曲目。
Exactly. And he knew this, because he knows my music. So maybe on the third or fourth song I played, the song "Straw Man," which is one of the ones that he had asked for-- and I'll play a little bit of it.
没错。他知道这一点，因为他了解我的音乐。所以也许在第三或第四首我演奏的歌中，那首“稻草人”，这是他要求的其中一首——我会弹一点点。
[GUITAR PLAYING AND SINGING] Never quite so clean. She makes the world around me seem lavender and winter green. When we're side by side. [END SINGING]
[吉他演奏和演唱] 从未如此干净。她让周围的世界显得如薰衣草和冬青般。当我们并肩时。[演唱结束]
And that chorus repeats several times. And after about the second chorus, I looked up. And I felt like she softened a little bit. And it seemed like the song was doing a little bit more of its job. And by the end of the song, it really did feel like it had changed something in the room. And she was sitting up a little straighter, maybe. And she was looking at me more. And I even saw her look at him a little and give a little smile. And that was a tiny gesture, but it was so good to see.
副歌重复了几次。大约在第二遍副歌后，我抬头看了看。我觉得她稍微软化了一些。看起来这首歌在某种程度上起到了更多的作用。到歌结束时，它确实感觉像是在房间里改变了一些东西。她坐得更直了些，也许。她更经常地看着我。我甚至看到她看了他一眼，给了一个小小的微笑。那是一个微小的姿态，但看到它真是太好了。
And so from there, was it better?
所以从那以后，有好一点吗？
Well, so then we got on a little bit of a roll. But with each song-- and even smaller increments, with each verse-- it seemed like they were symbolically and literally moving closer together. And in fact, by maybe song five or six, they actually were sitting next to each other. And I couldn't believe it. I couldn't believe it. I really didn't think there was any chance, and certainly from the beginning of the night until that point, there seemed like there was zero chance. But they started holding hands. And at one point in a song, she lay her head on his shoulder.
嗯，所以我们开始有点进展了。但随着每一首歌——甚至在每一句歌词的更小增量中——看起来他们象征性地和字面上都在向对方靠近。事实上，大约到第五或第六首歌时，他们实际上坐在一起了。我简直不敢相信。我简直不敢相信。我真的认为没有任何机会，肯定从夜晚开始到那时，看起来机会为零。但他们开始牵手了。在歌的某一点，她把头靠在了他的肩膀上。
So it's working. And I play a song thaT-- actually, they kiss. And that was a shock. And at that point, I thought this is it. We've done it. I wanted to slap the guy's hand. I felt great. But the mood had changed, but it was still painfully awkward. And if anything, more so now. Because I was now right across the coffee table from a couple who's making out as I'm singing. And now it felt totally wrong that I was there, just for different reasons. At one point they kissed and I locked eyes with her, right as they're kissing. And we both looked away immediately. But it happened.
所以它奏效了。我弹了一首歌……实际上，他们接吻了。那是一个冲击。在这一点上，我想这就是了。我们做到了。我想拍拍那个家伙的手。我感觉很棒。但气氛改变了，但仍然痛苦地尴尬。如果有什么的话，现在更是如此。因为我正坐在咖啡桌对面，看着一对在我唱歌时热吻的情侣。现在我觉得我在这里完全错了，只是原因不同而已。在某一点他们接吻时，我与她对视了，就在他们接吻时。我们俩立即看向别处。但这确实发生了。
And at one point, he and I met eyes at just a really badly-timed moment, where he was giving her one of these looks like, I'm your man. And I will be there for you forever. And we'll have beautiful children together. And there I am, and he and I are looking at each other suddenly for a second, but a very, very bad second of my life.
在某一点，他和我在一个时间点非常糟糕的时刻对视了，他给了她那种眼神，像是我才是你的男人。我会永远在那里支持你。我们将有漂亮的宝宝。而我在那里，他和我突然对视了一秒钟，但我生命中非常、非常糟糕的一秒钟。
So things move from horrible to exuberant to straight out creepy, it sounds like.
听起来事情从恐怖变得兴高采烈，变得直白地令人毛骨悚然。
I think that's fair. But at least what I'm singing, I can just get lost in the fact that the music is sort of working for them. And so as I finish the concert, she hugs me and he walks me out of the apartment and down into the elevator. I get to take the main elevator down this time. And he tells me something to the effect of, you never know how things are going to work out. But I think that you may have been the tipping point tonight. And that felt great. I was so happy.
我想那是公平的。但至少我唱的歌，我只是沉浸在音乐对他们起作用的事实中。所以当我结束音乐会时，她拥抱了我，他把我送出公寓，下到电梯。我这次可以乘主电梯下去。他告诉了我类似这样的话，你永远不知道事情会如何发展。但我认为你可能是今晚的转折点。那感觉太棒了。我太高兴了。
Right. Your music brought these people together.
对。你的音乐把这些人带到了一起。
Brought them together in the first place, maybe, brought them back together now. It was perfect. Even when I had tried to serenade ex-girlfriends to get them back, directly, that hadn't worked.
首先把他们带到一起，也许，现在又把他们带回一起。这太完美了。即使当我试图给前女友唱歌来挽回她们时，直接地，那也没有奏效。
A few months after all this, David Berkeley was back in California, doing a show in Los Angeles. And the guy emailed him, asking if David would give him two spots on the guest list. But the guy did not bring the girl. He came with a buddy. And he told David afterwards that things didn't work out. Incredibly, David says that he would do this all over again if somebody else asked him to do it. And as for the guy--
这一切发生几个月后，大卫·伯克利回到了加州，在洛杉矶做了一场演出。那个家伙给他发了电子邮件，询问大卫是否能给他两个客座名单的名额。但那个家伙没带那个女孩。他是和朋友一起来的。他事后告诉大卫，事情没成。令人难以置信的是，大卫说如果还有人要求他这样做，他会再做一次。至于那个家伙——
OK, after this failure, would he try another concert in his apartment?
好的，这次失败后，他还会尝试在他的公寓里举办另一场音乐会吗？
I know he would. And, in fact, I know that he would do it again with me, because he's made that clear.
我知道他会。事实上，我知道他会再次找我，因为他已经表现得很清楚了。
What?
什么？
He's made it clear that if he has another girl, he hopes the situation will arise where he can have me come and do another serenade.
他表现得很清楚，如果他有另一个女孩，他希望出现这样的情况，他可以让我来再做一次小夜曲。
But wait, would you go?
等等，你会去吗？
What would be funny is that my exclusive knowledge of him is related to this other episode that we wouldn't be able to talk about, this other girl where I did the same thing. And of course, the new girl isn't going to want to know about the old girl, and is certainly not going to want to know that he did the same trick.
有趣的是，我对他的独家了解与我们无法谈论的这个其他插曲有关，这个我做了同样事情的另一个女孩。当然，新女孩不想知道旧女孩的事情，肯定也不想知道他使用了同样的伎俩。
Yeah, I was just thinking that. It definitely takes the romantic idealism off the whole thing.
是啊，我刚才就在想那个。它绝对让整个事情失去了浪漫主义的理想化。
Yeah. Then it starts to get bizarre in a whole other way. Because now I'm sort of his guy. And I'm not sure about that.
是啊。然后它开始以一种全新的方式变得离奇。因为现在我成了他的专属歌手。我不确定那个。
David Berkeley. His newest album is called Strange Light. Marshall Lewy helped us produce that story.
大卫·伯克利。他的最新专辑叫《奇怪的光》。马歇尔·卢伊帮助我们制作了这个故事。
[MUSIC - "ISN'T IT ROMANTIC" BY ELLA FITZGERALD]
[音乐 - 艾拉·费兹杰拉的“难道不浪漫吗”]
Act Three, Prisoner of the Heart. So we've had parents in Harlem going all out to change the lives of their kids. We've had a guy going all out to get a girl. Now in this act, we have a daughter who goes all out, goes as far as anybody possibly could to get close to her mom. Douglas McGray tells the story.
第三幕，心灵的囚徒。所以我们有哈雷姆的家长全力以赴改变孩子的生活。我们有一个家伙全力以赴赢得一个女孩。现在在这一幕中，我们有一个全力以赴的女儿，走到了任何人可能走的最远，去接近她的妈妈。道格拉斯·麦格雷讲述了这个故事。
21 years ago, Daisy Benson brought a gun to an argument. She says she didn't mean to shoot, and that may be true. But you bring a gun to an argument, a lot can go wrong. Daisy was convicted of murder, given 15 to life, and sent away to prison hundreds of miles from her home, a small, poor town in Northern California. Seven years later, her family saved up enough to visit. That's when her daughter Robin, she was in her 20s at the time, hatched a plan that sounded so crazy when Daisy first told me about it, I thought, this can't be true. But then I tracked down Robin, and they both remember it starting exactly the same way. Here's Daisy, then Robin.
21年前，黛西·本森带了一把枪去争论。她说她没打算开枪，这可能是真的。但你带一把枪去争论，很多事情都可能出错。黛西被判谋杀罪，被判15年至终身监禁，并被送往离她家数百英里远的监狱，那是加州北部一个小而贫困的城镇。七年后，她的家人攒够了钱去探视。那时她的女儿罗宾，当时她二十多岁，策划了一个计划，当黛西第一次告诉我时，它听起来太疯狂了，我想，这不可能是真的。但后来我找到了罗宾，她们都记得它正是从那种方式开始的。这是黛西，然后是罗宾。
I'd had one visit. My ex-husband had come. He brought my daughter. And she stood with her fingers in the chicken wire, looking out over the yard. And I could see, she was just taking inventory from side to side, what she could see. And she said to me, and I'll never forget it, this wouldn't be too bad for the two of us, mom. She said, we could be here together. And I said--
我有过一次探视。我的前夫来了。他带了我的女儿。她站在鸡丝网边，看着院子。我能看到，她正在侧头盘点她所能看到的一切。她对我说，我永远不会忘记，这对我们俩来说并不太糟，妈妈。她说，我们可以待在一起。我说——
She said, don't even think about. She already knew what I was thinking when I got there.
她说，别想了。当我到达那里时，她已经知道我在想什么了。
Because I could see it working in her head. You can tell when kids are doing something. Don't even think about it.
因为我能看到它在她的脑子里运作。你能看出孩子们什么时候在搞事情。别想了。
And what did she say?
她说了什么？
She was just solemn. She was very serious about what she was saying.
她只是严肃的。她对她说的话非常认真。
She was trying to get me to look at her. And I was just looking around.
她试图让我看着她。我只是在四处看。
Well, what where you looking around for? Were you looking to see, could I do this?
嗯，你在找什么？你是想看看，我能这样做吗？
Yeah. And I was like, this ain't so bad.
是啊。而且我想，这并不太糟。
Was life outside pretty bad then?
那时候外面的生活很糟糕吗？
Life outside was probably a lot worse than in there at the time. I was just in a drug life. I did drugs. I was on the street. And so I would do what I had to do. And all kinds of stuff. It was hard.
外面的生活当时可能比里面糟得多。我只是在吸毒生活。我吸毒。我在街头。所以我不得不做我必须做的事情。还有各种各样的事情。那很难。
So Robin was already living the kind of life that might lead to prison. She didn't care. But then suddenly, she did. She could go to jail and be with her mom. A year later, when she and her friends got hauled in for stealing, she told me she confessed to everything, even things she hadn't done.
所以罗宾已经在过那种可能导致入狱的生活。她不在乎。但后来突然，她想了。她可以去坐牢，和妈妈在一起。一年后，当她和朋友因偷窃被抓时，她告诉我她承认了一切，甚至包括她没做过的事情。
When my mom went prison, it was almost like my mom died to me. I missed her so bad, I got in trouble just to get in trouble. Because I didn't really have nothin' out there. I just got in trouble to get in trouble, and kept getting in trouble until they caught me. I told the judge, I said, I did it. He said, no wait a minute, you need representation. I said, no, I did it. I want you to sentence me. I want to go to prison. Because I wanted to go see my mom.
当我妈妈入狱时，这对我来说几乎就像我妈妈死了。我太想她了，我陷入麻烦只是为了陷入麻烦。因为我外面真的什么都没有。我只是为了惹麻烦而惹麻烦，一直惹麻烦直到他们抓住我。我告诉法官，我说，是我做的。他说，不等等，你需要辩护。我说，不，是我做的。我想要你判我刑。我想去监狱。因为我想去见我妈妈。
When Daisy went away, California had one small prison for women called CIW. But longer sentences and a three strikes law helped set off a prison boom. The state had to build two more. Robin got sentenced to one of the new ones, up north-- not part of the plan. Now she had to finagle a transfer somehow. She roamed the yard, looking for advice.
当黛西离开时，加州有一所名为CIW的小型女子监狱。但更长的刑期和“三振出局法”推动了监狱热潮。该州不得不又建了两所。罗宾被判处到北方的新监狱之一——不在计划之内。现在她必须想方设法转院。她在院子里游荡，寻求建议。
I started asking people, how do I get to CIW? My mom's down there.
我开始问别人，我怎样才能去CIW？我妈妈在那儿。
Eventually, someone told her about a prison work program that would get her shipped south where Daisy was. One day, a letter came for Daisy, postmarked from another prison. She couldn't believe what it said. And the letter had taken so long to get there, that the same day it arrived-- well, I'll let Daisy tell it.
最终，有人告诉她一个监狱工作项目，可以把她运往南方，也就是黛西所在的地方。有一天，一封信寄给黛西，是从另一所监狱邮寄的。她不敢相信信里的内容。而且那封信到达的时间太长了，以至于在它到达的同一天——嗯，让黛西自己说吧。
I came to the front office. And I rounded the corner, and there was my child, standing there in a muumuu. And my legs just buckled.
我来到前台。我绕过拐角，那是我的孩子，穿着一件穆穆袍站在那里。我的腿瘫软了。
She acted like she was going to fall apart or something. Oh my God, my baby. She acted like she was going to faint, and all kinds of stuff.
她表现得好像要崩溃了似的。天哪，我的宝贝。她表现得好像要晕倒了，之类的。
It was the greatest moment, but it was the saddest moment-- ooh-- to be able to see her. But to see her in this setting was overwhelming. And I was just hanging on to her. We just locked up. She had her arms around me. And I had my arms around her. And everybody was crying. The cop was crying. Everybody around us was crying. And I know that every one of them wanted it to be their daughter. Everybody wanted-- it was the joy--
那是最好的时刻，但那是悲伤的时刻——喔——能够见到她。但在这种环境下见到她让人不知所措。我只是挂在她身上。我们只是锁在一起。她抱着我。我抱着她。每个人都在哭。警察在哭。我们周围的每个人都在哭。我知道他们中的每一个都希望那是他们自己的女儿。每个人都希望——那是喜悦——
These are other prisoners?
这些是其他囚犯吗？
Yeah. Not to have your child in prison, but to have your arms around her. My legs were so weak. I stood back and I just asked, what the hell are you doing here? And she just grabbed me again. And she was holding on to me, loving me. She said, I need my mom. It was wonderful. Because I don't let people touch me in here. People don't hug me. People don't squeeze me. But she hugs me and squeezes me.
是啊。不是让你的孩子进监狱，而是能够抱着她。我的腿太软了。我退后一步，只是问，你到底在这里做什么？她只是又抱住了我。她抱着我，爱着我。她说，我需要妈妈。这太棒了。因为我不让人碰我。人们不拥抱我。人们不挤压我。但她拥抱我，挤压我。
Mothers, daughters, sisters, cousins-- they cross paths in here more than you'd think. The stories aren't always happy. A staff person told me, yeah, we had identical twins in here one time. And one of them lit herself on fire. Mother/daughter cell mates? That he'd never seen. But when Daisy asked, the administration said yes. So Robin moved in. They shared eight feet square, if that, with bunk beds. A year after she first stared out at the prison yard, Robin got her wish. Prison was a lot harsher than Robin expected, just like her mom had said it would be.
母亲、女儿、姐妹、堂姐妹——她们在这里交叉的路径比你想象的要多。故事并不总是快乐的。一位工作人员告诉我，是的，我们曾经有过一对同卵双胞胎在这里。其中一个把自己点火烧了。母女同住一个牢房？他从没见过。但当黛西要求时，行政部门说了同意。所以罗宾搬了进去。她们分享着八英尺见方，如果有的话，里面有双层床。在她第一次凝视监狱院子一年后，罗宾如愿以偿。监狱比罗宾预想的要严酷得多，就像她妈妈说的会那样。
I think when I first went to prison, I was going down there to protect her, but she protected me. She introduced me and pointed to everyone that was on the yard-- people, what they were there for. And stay away from that one. And then she'd introduce me to them. The ones that she told me to stay away from, she'd say, this is my daughter, and I'll kill you if you mess with her.
我想当我第一次去监狱时，我是去那里保护她，但她保护了我。她介绍我认识并向我指出院子里的每个人——人们，他们为什么在这里。并且远离那一个。然后她会把我介绍给他们。那些她告诉我远离的人，她会说，这是我的女儿，如果你招惹她，我就杀了你。
I was probably trying to control her. I was keeping her away from the riff-raff.
我可能是在试图控制她。我让她远离那些混混。
A lot of their time together was just fun, for prison anyway.
她们在一起的大部分时间只是很有趣，对监狱而言。
We did pedicures. She did my toes, I did her toes. It was just girls, just girls.
我们做了足疗。她修我的脚趾，我修她的脚趾。这只是女孩，只是女孩。
One time we had Thanksgiving dinner around the yard. Just come on, mom. Just lay down and I'll take you on a trip. We'll go to the river. Close your eyes.
有一次我们在院子里吃了感恩节晚餐。只是过来，妈妈。躺下，我会带你去旅行。我们去河边。闭上眼睛。
And then what? And then you would describe it?
然后呢？然后你就会描述它？
Yeah. And I'd tell her, OK, we're on the river. Can you hear the water? Do you hear the birds? Just that was enough.
是啊。我会告诉她，好的，我们在河边。你能听到水声吗？你能听到鸟声吗？这就足够了。
Even before she went to prison, Daisy had been gone a lot, working at the canneries or the turkey plant, driving a bus. Now there was none of that, no distractions.
甚至在她入狱之前，黛西也经常不在家，在罐头厂或火鸡厂工作，开公交车。现在什么都没有了，没有干扰。
I think that that's probably some of the best times in our lives together. Because nobody could get in between us. There was nothing to interfere with the relationship of mom and daughter.
我认为那可能确实是我们在一起生活中最好的时光。因为没人能介入我们之间。没有什么能干扰母女的关系。
They were in together for almost a year. When the time came for Robin to be released, she was ready. Daisy wasn't.
她们在一起待了近一年。当罗宾获释的时间到来时，她准备好了。黛西没有。
There was such an emptiness when she was gone. And it was almost like a dream that she had been here. You know, like I'd dreamed the whole dang thing up. But I get another sweet and sour moment. You're so happy that it happened. But you're so sorry that they're going to go.
当她离开时，有一种虚空。就好像她在这里是一个梦。你知道，就像我梦到了整个该死的事情。但我又得到了另一个苦乐参半的时刻。你很高兴它发生了。但你又很遗憾他们要走了。
Robin's not doing so well these days. Since her time with her mom, more than 10 years ago, she's been in and out of prison. The more time a person spends inside, the harder it is to make a life outside.
罗宾这些日子过得不太好。自从十多年前她和妈妈在一起后，她一直进出监狱。一个人在里面待的时间越长，在外面谋生就越难。
I never felt like I'd be right until my mom gets out. I'm not going to be right. Here I'm 42 years old, just staying where I can, don't have a job. Nothing, nothing. I mean, I've tried to complete my GED and stuff quite a few times. And I went to beauty college and I graduated. But I didn't go to state board. And it's just like, I never think I'm going to win.
我从未觉得我会恢复正常直到我妈妈出来。我不会恢复正常。我今年42岁了，只能住在我能住的地方，没有工作。什么都没有，什么都没有。我的意思是，我尝试完成我的GED（同等学历）测试很多次了。我去读了美容学校，我毕业了。但我没去参加州委员会考试。这就像，我从不认为我会赢。
Is there anything that gives you hope?
有什么给你希望吗？
Just my mom getting out. That's the only hope I've got anymore.
只是我妈妈出来。那是我剩下的唯一希望了。
A couple months ago, Daisy wrote me a letter that said she might be home by Thanksgiving. The parole board approved her for release, but the governor has the final say. And it's easier to say no. Earlier this year, facing a budget crisis, and a prison system that costs $10 billion a year-- five times more than Texas spends-- the governor tried to let some nonviolent offenders out early. Legislators revolted. They cut from schools instead.
几个月前，黛西写信给我说她可能在感恩节前回家。假释委员会批准她获释，但州长拥有最终决定权。而且说“不”更容易。今年早些时候，面对预算危机，以及一个每年耗资100亿美元——比德州支出多五倍——的监狱系统，州长试图提前释放一些非暴力犯罪者。立法者造反了。他们反而从学校削减资金。
Daisy's 59 now. But like most of the lifers, she seems a lot older. A walker keeps her upright. A pacemaker keeps her heart going. She's lost most of her front teeth. When she laughs, she covers her mouth. Robin writes to her mother, but she's only gone back to see her once since she boarded a prison bus and drove out through the gate. Her mom told her not to look back, but she did. She does.
黛西现在59岁了。但像大多数终身监禁者一样，她看起来老多了。一个步行器让她保持直立。一个起搏器维持着她的心脏跳动。她大部分前牙都没了。当她大笑时，她遮住嘴。罗宾写信给她妈妈，但自从她登上监狱巴士并开车穿过大门以来，她只回去看过她一次。她妈妈告诉她不要回头，但她回了。她确实回头了。
Douglas McGray. He's an Irvine fellow at the New America Foundation.
道格拉斯·麦格雷。他是新美国基金会的欧文研究员。
Well, our program was produced today by Jane Feltes and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Sarah Koenig, Lisa Pollak, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Adrianne Mathiowetz runs our website. Seth Lind is our Production Manager. Production help from P.J. Vogt and Aaron Scott. Jessica Hopper is our Music Consultant. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
嗯，我们的节目今天由简·费尔特斯和我自己制作，还有亚历克斯·布卢姆伯格、萨拉·凯尼格、丽莎·波拉克、罗宾·塞米恩、阿丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克。我们的高级制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。阿德里安娜·马蒂奥维茨运营我们的网站。塞思·林德是我们的制作经理。P.J.沃格特和亚伦·斯科特提供制作帮助。杰西卡·霍珀是我们的音乐顾问。《美国生活》由公共广播国际分发。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助鸣谢]
WBEZ Management oversight for our program by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia, who tells me all the time--
WBEZ对我们节目的管理监督，由我们的老板，托雷·马拉蒂亚先生，他一直告诉我——
I'm your man. And I will be there for you forever. And we'll have beautiful children together.
我才是你的男人。我会永远在那里支持你。我们将有漂亮的宝宝。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周回来，带来更多《美国生活》的故事。